far left mob wins again new york times
opinion editor james bennett forced to
resign
after employees revolted over the
paper's decision to publish an op-ed by
senator tom cotton
staffers were furious over cotton saying
the military
should be used to stop the looting and
the rioting
the senators slamming the paper over
what happened
they totally surrendered to a woke
child mob from their own newsroom that
apparently gets triggered if they're
presented with any opinion
contrary to their own as opposed to
telling the woke children in their
newsroom this is the workplace
not a social justice seminar on campus
so katie i think republicans for many
many years have been wondering how to
get a new york times opinion editor
fired and i think tom cotton
finally figured it out how
i love the woke child mob classification
of this
it's absolutely true and i love that his
office has been fighting back
you know this is just a solidification
that the new york times has become a
far-left newspaper not interested
in liberalism but interested in leftism
and that's been proven considering
they're willing to run op-eds by
dictators like
you know the the dictator in turkey or
seppie erdogan
they're willing to run op-eds in defense
of pedophilia but
you run an op-ed trying to squash
rioting then
well the editor has to resign because
the woke child mob comes after you
i want that on a t-shirt woke child yeah
so gripped greg it seemed like the
new york times was more upset by an
op-ed than they were the fact that their
city had been burned to the ground
of course they have amazing priorities
remember they had bill ayers
write an op-ed on 9 11. of course that
was just bad timing
um here's the but this isn't even the
worst part of the woke mob
it is going to be impossible to solve
any kind of racial issues if you aren't
permitted to discuss it
instead you must accept blindly the
terms of the debate
that's the real intolerance you have to
accept the terms
and kneel genuflect and confess your
original sins
which i'm sorry it ain't gonna happen
with me and given that corporations now
are essentially sponsoring the ongoing
rage-a-thon
we are incentivizing rage because we are
just simply rewarding it
so that to me on a long term
and in a more violent way in in a
scarier way is a bigger problem
than the new york times you know
freaking out over a column
yeah dana how do you see things going
out the new york times and pretty much
everywhere now that we've seen the power
of the mob
well i think that you could look at the
trajectory of how uh solsberger the head
of the
organization uh comment on it he first
defended it saying i believe in the
principles of openness to a range of
opinions even those we may disagree with
and then just hours later
he told the newsroom in a town hall that
the op-ed was contemptuous
that the piece should not have been
published so if he's
able if he caves within hours just
imagine
where else this is going to end up and i
would point out that
the employees that complained they
seemed very organized
and they all used workplace safety
language
you know from the hr handbook to make
sure that their point was made and that
they would be taken seriously so i do
believe that you will see this elsewhere
yeah that language scares a lot of
people juan you know i just learned that
federal troops have been used in uh you
know to fight the democrat
governors in the south over
desegregation when they tried to block
that they were used
to quell the la riots george washington
used them they were using the virgin
islands
it's not that crazy of an idea is it
well the governor has to ask unless you
do something like
orville falbas did in little rock which
is defy ruling from the supreme court in
which case
you can understand but you know i mean
you know i found
cotton's argument uh alarming but i
think that it's legitimate
to air the argument and let us as
americans
you know deal with it and and say is it
legit
for the federal troops to be here
dealing with a peaceful protest
arguably suppressing dissent and
increasing the chances of confrontation
if looting is your
your argument well i think federal
troops uh
using helicopters and uh smoke bombs and
what do they call it pepper
balls or whatever because they don't
want to call it pepper spray i think
that's a
that's a big threat so we should have
that argument jesse
all right one very open-minded from you
today
i don't know what's going on but i like
it